[Music]
a Marvel hero gets a new look in Black
Panther wakanda forever but some sci-fi
fans are pretty sure they've seen it
before warning spoilers ahead in wakanda
Forever the matter of t'challa's
successor as the Black Panther looms
large over the early events of the film
that said the continuing stories of
Heroes like Nakia and Baku and Okoye are
integral to wakanda forever too in Black
Panther Okoye is ahead of the Dora
milage a team of powerful warriors
wakanda forever then shakes up her role
in the Dora melange briefly sending her
away from the team she once LED before
shuri urges her to return When okay
rejoins Adora milage sure he provides
her in addition to a NECA and IO with
new combat suits to viewers familiar
with Marvel Comics the three door milage
members donning these suits constitutes
an Easter egg in wakanda Forever
introducing the Midnight's angels to the
Marvel Cinematic Universe shuri spends a
lot of time in wakanda forever trying to
get so Courier into that updated suit of
armor but she notably pushes back
preferring the get-up to which she's
accustomed as it turns out a lot of fans
agree with okoyo's criticisms of the
Midnight's Angels suit earlier in the
film why well they think the suit looks
a little too much like Predator armor
and not in a good way
one Reddit user for example argued that
shuri should have taken okoye's initial
reluctance to wear her new armor to
heart before finalizing its design in a
reply to this comment another user
compared the suit's appearance to the
Predator film's titular bad guy
specifically they drew comparisons
between the Midnight's Angels armor and
the Predator killer suit from the 2018
Predator film rather than make any
comparisons one Reddit user simply wrote
Okoye was right that suit is hideous
it turns out that this isn't a new
comparison in September 2022 Disney
displayed some costumes from wakanda
Forever at its annual d23 Expo including
a suit of midnight Angel's armor an
image shared on Twitter by MCU direct
LED fans to begin comparing its
appearance to the iconic predator's lurk
replies from no less than five separate
users all made the same Predator
comparison another Twitter user likewise
shared that the suit reminded them of
the predator on the Day images of it
circulated online that said at this
point in time much of the negativity
about the suits design had yet to
manifest a flood of users took to social
media to criticize the midnight Angel's
outfit after viewing wakanda forever one
person on Twitter zeroed in on its
headpiece it's most predator-like
components while another user went so
far as to call the appearance of the
midnight Angels armor as being the
film's only weak point
ouch we know what you whisper wakanda
forever only just barely introduces the
midnight Angels leaving plenty of room
for their return in a future MCU project
and there are plenty of stories and
comics about them to explore it's
entirely possible then that at the time
of their return Marvel could revise
their Predator ask appearance to be
something a little less monstrous on the
other hand it's not like they changed up
the look from the comics merch and
viewers at large May simply grow
accustomed to the way the Midnight's
angels look after seeing them in action
again whenever their next outing may be